minutes, on comprend l'horreur
de cette avec Sébastien
Desrosiers.
- Alvtyna voyage léger, elle
s'apprête à allte à allte à alla
mère de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique.
Ukrainienne, installée à
Montréal depuis plus de 10 ans,
sa vie et celle de son conjoint
ont été complètement chamboulées
par la guerre.
- Voir ça comme ça, pour des
gens qui n'ont rien fait pour...
pour mériter ce sort, c'est...
c'est dur à digérer. C'est
vraiment dur à digérer. C'est
pas comme ça, l'Ukraine que j'ai
l y a à peine quelques
mois.
- Puis personne pensait que ça
allait arriver.
- Le couple est allé rendre
visite  aux parents d'Alevtyna
il y a à peine six mois. Olena
et Ayoub habitent Kryvyi Rih,
une ville industrielle du centre
du pays, lieu de naissance du
président Zelensky menacés par
les troupes russes.
ALEVTYNA MARKINA, Montréalaise
d'origine ukrainienne
-  Donc, c'est beaucoup de
stress. Puis en plus, ma mère,
elle était diagnostiquée avec un
cancer de l'intestin au mois de
janvier. C'était un jour avants.
- Olena a commencé ses
traitements de chimiothérapie au
jour quatre de la guerre.
(sirène)
Ils ont été interrompus par des
sirènes comme celle-ci qui l'ont
forcé à se réfugier au sous-sol
de l'hôpital.
Les médecins lui ont dit de ne
pas revenir, trop dangereux, et
les médicaments commencent à
manquer.
AYOUB DASSER,
conjoint d'Alevtyna Markina
- Donc, c'est question de vie ou
de mort. On ne peut pas faire de
traitement, il faut qu'elle soit
traitée si... elle est prête à
se battre.
- C'est ma mère. Donc, je ne
peux paspeux paspeux paspeux pa.
- Direction : l'aéroport,
Alevtyna va ramener sa mère
aujourd'hui réfugiée en Pologne.
Il aura fallu près de 48 heures
un aller-retour Montréal-
Varsovie, Ayoub est là pour
le souhaiter bienvenue. Il est
compagné de la fille d'Alevtyna
que sa grand-mère ne pensait
plus revoir. Elle a réussi, elle
a ramené Olena qui refusait
obstinément de quitter
sa maison.
Elle a dû laisser derrière elle
son mari qui est chirurgien
orthopédiste, il soignait
soldats, dit-elle, mais il
manque de tout. Les sirènes
résonnent toutes les nuits,
explique-t-elle, il faut dormir
dans les corridas et prier pour
que les bons nous épargnent.
- Le moitié du vol, elle apleur:
"j'espère qu'ici, ils peuvent me
traiter parce que sinon, si je
dois retourner en Ukraine, il y
a même pas d'aéroport."
- Elle a pu entrer au pays grâce
un visa de touriste encore
valide, mais le plus dur res
faire.
STÉPHANIE VALOIS,
présidente, Asso. québécoise
des avocats et avocates en droit
de l'immigration
- Son visa de visiteur a été
transformé dans le visa spécial
Canada-Ukraine. Et pour les
personnes qui bénéficient de ce
visa là, arrivant Canada, i
peuvent obtenir un permis de
travail ouvert.
- Ce permis de travail,
explique-t-elle, donne accès aux
soins de santé.
C'est également ce qu'indique le
ministre fédéral de
l'immigration.
- La seule question qui vaille,
c'est quels documents ils vont
pouvoir présenter aux médecins.
- Olena dort mieux maintenant,mn
corps est ici, alors que sa tête
est en Ukraine. Elle se sent
coupable d'être en sécurité,
alors que son mari est là-bas.Mt
condamnée à mort.
- Moi, je dis : écoute, maman,
on va pas te laisser tomber, on.
Mais je ne suis pas capable à
payer pour ça tout seul, et d'un
autre côté, je ne peux pas
laisser ma mère décéder.- Le Que
les Ukrainiens
- Le Québec a aussi promis quelà
des soins mais on ne leur a
remis aucun document et elles ne
savent pas quand elles pourront
aller à l'hôpital.
- Je ne dis pas ça, mais je sen.
(elle sanglote)
Excusez, c'est... c'est très
difficile. J'ai aussi de la
misère à croire.  J'ai déjà
comme pas de pays, si je n'avai.
- Elle compte bien faire
d'Olena une double survivante.
- J'aimerais me réveiller et
savoir que la guerre estterminé.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Mo